bonjour mme tyson et merci d'être là en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
à langon c'est que la situation est
grave en polynésie 100 % des lits de
réanimation sont d'ailleurs occupé à
tahiti est-ce que l'annoncent finalement
d'un couvre feu pourrait diminuer la
charge de travail des soignants est ce
que vous attendez à de nouvelles
restrictions comme c'est déjà le cas en
guadeloupe et en martinique avec
peut-être un nouveau confinement strict
alors écoutez on est suspendu aux
décisions de l'état et donc au travers
du haut commissaire le péché chez nous
pour voir si jamais ce confinement on va
se va arriver ou pas ce qui est vrai
c'est que le que le feu ne va pas
résoudre l'épidémie en elle-même mais en
diminuant le nombre d'incidents a
reconnu qu'ils peuvent se produit tous
les soirs les accidents de deux roues de
véhicules les tout ce qui est un peu
voilà lié à l'activité nocturne
notamment de la jeunesse ça va permettre
de soulager les soignants qui sont déjà
flux tendu alors malgré la quatrième
vague industrie touristique tourner à
plein régime on sait que les frontières
sont toujours ouvertes
est ce que le rétablissement de l'état
d'urgence pourrait changer justement
cette ouverture des frontières en tout
cas
c'est le difficile équilibre à réaliser
on peut la sécurité sanitaire et puis le
maintien de l'activité économique dans
un territoire une collectivité qui
effectivement essentiellement
touristique dès lors qu'on parle de
fermeture des frontières on parle à la
fois de difficultés financières une
autre compagnie aérienne air tahiti nui
et on parle derrière sa difficulté pour
le secteur politique dans son ensemble
et c'est évidemment la grosse crainte
ici
une question également concernant la
vaccination
on le disait le pays est à la traîne
seuls 27% des habitants ont reçu un
schéma vaccinal
complet comment expliquer ce faible taux
pourquoi les voilà les habitants de
l'est ne sont pas friands d'aller se
faire vacciner
alors mon opinion est que il ya eu je
pense un défaut d'information ou une
mauvaise communication autour de cette
vaccination il ya évidemment les anti
vaccins qui pensent que la vaccination
va les affaires capter la 5g ou d'autres
bêtises de ce genre mais il ya aussi des
gens de bonne foi qu'ils n'ont pas
accompli réellement l'utilité de la
vaccination
et qui se disent bon moi je ne voyage
pas toute façon je n'ai pas les moyens
de voyager ce qui est le cas d'une
grande majorité des polynésiens et donc
je n'ai pas vraiment besoin d'être
vaccinés on l'a vu lors de l'ouverture
des vaccinodromes auto début ceux qui se
sont précipités pour se faire vacciner
ce sont plus des catégories aisées bon
hormis les personnes à risque évidemment
les personnes âgées etc mais ce sont
surtout des personnes aisées qui soit
pour le loisir soit pour leur profession
on sont amenés à voyager beaucoup à
l'étranger
la vaccination obligatoire pourrait
d'ailleurs devenir
la vaccination pourrait devenir
obligatoire pour pour les soignants est
ce que là aussi de ce côté là vous
sentez des réticences
alors lire eh oui tout comme en
métropole certaine réticence les
syndicats de soignants se sont exprimé
là dessus il préférait que cette
vaccination
reste on va dire livre ici frontier pour
les personnels soignants pour l'instant
les dispositions qui ont été votées
concernant le pass and i ter dont ont
toutes ses modalités ne s'applique pas
en polynésie mais si elle devenait très
tendue évidemment ça ça poserait
question
là aussi en polynésie comme en métropole
les avis sont partagés
dernière question est-ce que voilà vous
reproché au gouvernement d'avoir un
petit peu failli dans cette crise
sanitaire en polynésie qui est justement
plus touchées en tout cas touchés
actuellement beaucoup plus que la
métropole
est là et cette circulation du dieu du
virus finalement est-ce qu'elle a un
lien avec justement la réticence
peut-être des polynésiens à respecter
les mesures sanitaires
alors je dirais pas que les polynésiens
ne respectent pas les mesures sanitaires
mais
celles qui ne les comprennent pas
réellement il y a eu des signaux envoyés
y compris lors de la visite du président
macron dernièrement on était déjà en
montée de l'épidémie le variant delta
était arrivé
et quand la visite du président macron a
eu lieu on a on a vu des radars ce
rassemblement public pour l'accueillir
de 3000 personnes 2000 personnes avec ou
sans masque sans respect des distances
minimum et donc forcément quand le chef
de l'état lui-même
participent à ce genre de grands
rassemblements sans respect des
gestes-barrières
comprimés que ça envoie un mauvais
signal merci beaucoup en tout cas taiwo
le fait d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes député gilbert
en polynésie française